>>David Lieber: Good morning Google Chicago.
[speaking in background]
My name is David Lieber. I'm with the State
and Local Public Policy Team here. We're obviously
thrilled to have Rahm Emanuel, Mayoral Candidate
for Chicago here today for a fireside chat
with Jim Lecinski, the unofficial mayor of
the Chicago office.
[laughter]
So this is a continuation of our fireside
campaign chats which is a program we inaugurated
in 2008. Today, however, represents the first
time that we are doing an event outside of
Mountain View, and obviously there's no better
place to do that than the City of Chicago.
Our guest today, Rahm Emanuel, is a veteran
of two presidential administrations. He served
in the Clinton Administration from 1992 to
1998, rising to the position of Senior Advisor;
also served, as many of you know, as the Chief
of Staff to current President Barack Obama
from 2008 to 2010.
Before that, he served three terms in the
U.S. Congress representing the Fifth Congressional
District. In 2007, he became the Chair of
the House Democratic Caucus and in 2006 he
was the Chairman of the Democratic Congressional
Campaign Committee, the year that the Democrats
took over the House of Representatives.
If you look around, you'll notice that there
are no media present here today. We did, however,
extend an invite to @Mayor Emanuel to live
Tweet the event. Unfortunately he's holed
up in the igloo with Carl the intern, but
he does send his very saucy, saucy regrets
on not being able to make it.
But at this time, without further ado, I wanna
introduce Rahm Emanuel. Let's give him a warm
applause.
[applause]
>>Rahm Emanuel: Thank you.
What's this thing? Do you guys think I have
a kidney problem or something?
[laughter]
What is that?
Geez.
>>David Lieber: Just in case you're thirsty.
>>Rahm Emanuel: [laughs] Yeah. I didn't know
I was gonna sweat through the interview.
[laughter]
>David Lieber: Good. Well, well welcome Rahm.
We're very thrilled to have you here.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Um-hum.
>>David Lieber: And we know you've got a very
busy day today including the big Urban League
event debate on Fox tonight --
>>Rahm Emanuel: Um-hum.
>>David Lieber: so we're happy to be your
warm up act.
>>Rahm Emanuel: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>David Lieber: So. Well let's get started.
Speaking of Fox, I don't know if you watched
the Super Bowl this weekend but they had during
the Super Bowl on Fox incessant, everybody
here by the way was rooting against the Packers
--
[laughter]
just 'cause that's the Chicago thing to do.
But they had promos for a new Fox show on
called the "The Chicago Code" --
>>Rahm Emanuel: Um-hum.
>>David Lieber: in between the game. And it's
a fictitious new police commissioner played
by Jessica Biel. And in the promo that they
played, maybe you guys saw, very dramatically
one of the assistant's said to her, "What
makes you think you can change the way Chicago
works?" Right, remember this spot that ran
over and over in the football game?
So you've talked quite a bit about no bid
contract system, pay to play, you're running
a great TV spot right now talking about actually
getting city workers to do city work for us.
Alright, so I guess in the spirit of that
question posed on the Fox promo, we could
ask you the same question to get started.
What makes you, sir, think you can change
the way Chicago works?
>>Rahm Emanuel: Well first of all, I believe,
I mean I don't think it's a novel idea, but
that if you're gettin' a paycheck paid by
the taxpayers, the taxpayer are the people
you are beholden to. I don't think that should
be up for debate, but if we'll have that debate,
I'm ready.
I also want you to know I include the mayor,
I include anybody I would appoint, I include
the aldermen, I include anybody who gets paid
by the taxpayer is that we're gonna have a
mindset that we're beholden to taxpayers to
deliver a service for what they pay for.
Now you should know, my uncle's a former police
officer in the City of Chicago. You have a
lot of good workers in the city. I've visited
them during the blizzard out at O'Hare. They
moved that snow -- we had one of the worst
in a century. How you feelin', good?
>>David Lieber: [chuckles]
[laughter]
>>Rahm Emanuel: Okay? That's the pediatrician
son of me asks.
>>David Lieber: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Rahm Emanuel: I just wanna make sure everything's
okay 'cause you're holdin' it. I'm gettin'
nervous here man.
[laughter]
Now that does not go in the doctor's training
here, okay?
[laughter]
Let's get to that issue ?
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emaneual: it's more important than
what I --
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: okay here's the deal. They
did an incredible job during the blizzard.
>>David Lieber: [sighs]
>>Rahm Emanuel: And they do an incredible
job in our classrooms in very adverse `conditions.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: They do an incredible job
on our streets and when we need 'em, for God
forbid, if somethin' happens at your home
for a fire or whatever, they are there. They
do an incredible job every day.
But we gotta also be honest over the years,
stories about no show jobs, corruption, people
in middle management who've been convicted
here going to get another job here even though
they're convicted over here, and that has
created a basis for a show to talk about,
accept it as if it's built into the archaic
discussion, the Chicago Code.
>>David Lieber: Hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Now I want you to know I think
that the mayor, as I did when I was Chief
of Staff, as I did when I was a Congressman
or when I was Senior Advisor to President
Clinton, you get paid by the taxpayers, your
perspective regardless of where your position
is -- mayor, department head, beat officer,
and a lot of 'em as I said already have this
position, they already have this perspective
-- they are there to deliver a service whether
it's protecting, educating, cleaning snow
to the public and a lot of people already
have that mindset. There's a number of people
that did not -- we all know that -- and I'm
gonna change that perspective.
You guys talk here at Google about a view,
a perspective that helps you kinda is your,
it's your modus operandi.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: I want the modus operandi
in Chicago, and a lot of people have it and
they get hurt when other people they work
with don't have it, and it's usually at the
top, let's be also frank, that we work for
the taxpayers and the taxpayers expect to
get a good delivery of service for the dollars
that they pay. That should not be open for
discussion.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: But if we'll have that discussion,
I stand shoulder to shoulder with the taxpayers.
>>David Lieber: Absolutely. Okay.
Well let's move on. In advance of your visit,
we used a tool that we've built here at Google
called Google Moderator and it's a way to
have people submit questions and then you
can put a thumbs up, thumbs down, plus one,
minus one to raise the important questions
to the top and lower the less important questions.
>>Rahm Emanuel: What happens if the thumb
is like this?
>>David Lieber: We've [laughs]
[laughter]
we've used that with the President and others
and we used it for your visit here today.
>>Rahm Emanuel: [laughs]
>>David Lieber: And not surprisingly, you
mentioned it in your comments there, the most
popular number one topic that these folks
wanted to hear you talk about was education
and the Chicago Public Schools.
Can you talk a little bit about your plan
for the schools? There was lots of questions,
I live in Hyde Park. How do you plan to make
sure every child in the city has access to
a school as prestigious and high standard
with a free education that's as good as the
Ray and Bret Harte Elementary School in Hyde
Park?
>>Rahm Emanuel: Okay. Well, first of all,
while I think all the issues that I talk about:
economic development and reforming city government,
bringing safety to our streets and strength
to our schools, those are I think the building
blocks. The point of this spirit is without
a doubt education, without a doubt.
Now you don't know this, but in a former life
I had a scholarship once to the Joffrey Ballet;
didn't take it, purposely to make my mother
miserable.
[laughter]
But my wife, when I met her, we'd gotten a
master's in art history at University of Chicago
and I met her when she was working at the
Art Institute.
You can have a world class ballet company
in a city, and we do, you can have a world
class opera in a city, and we do. But if half
your kids aren't graduating from high school,
you're not gonna be a world class city much
longer. And that's my perspective and I say
that with the utmost passion for the arts
and culture. And because it's not only it's
important to your development but important
to the city's development.
Now we have two expecting mothers here, but
here's the deal. One of the most significant
thing I did as a Congressman was I used to
do my office hours at grocery stores and I
would just meet people. I didn't wanna do
town halls, I wanted to just meet people,
regular people wherever they were in their
lives. I was at the Lincoln and Column Jewel
--
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: and a young man came up [clears
throat] could have been in this room, but
he happened to a lawyer, his wife was in advertising
or accounting. He had a four year old. Thursday
night he's runnin' off to the Jewel --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: and he's says, "If I don't
have a good local school, my wife and I are
gonna move to the suburbs.
>>David Lieber: Yep.
>>Rahm Emanuel: He says, "I don't wanna pay
property taxes and then a private tuition."
Okay, for those who don't have kids, you'll
be facing this one day. For these two ladies,
they'll be facing this sooner than you if
you're not facing it today.
Now my view is, on education, and I say this
as a person who's gotten two things from his
parents and both are essential: their love
and education. That is why I have been able
to achieve what I've been able to achieve
in my life. That's what really what I view
as. And I view it also as a parent who's very
involved in his own kids' education.
Now first I wanna make every school in the
City of Chicago, we'd be the first school
system in the country, where every school
will have a five year performance contract.
So I can evaluate year by year or over a two
year period whether that principal, who ultimately
is the CEO for that school, is on the way
to making the improvements in that school
and are they being managed, the teachers as
well as the principal, towards those goals
we've measured? The successful charters do
it. I want the whole school system to do it.
Second, beyond the principal is the teacher.
Everything I'm investing in is proven over
a period of time. It's not the fad of the
day in education. Teachers, now this is gonna
take a while and I wanna spend on a lot of
time on this, since it's the number one issue
--
>>David Lieber: Yep.
>>Rahm Emanuel: and it's my number one passion.
Second the teachers. We have very good teachers
working in adverse conditions, you should
know that. But I wanna raise the quality of
all of the teachers in the schools. And I
say that because you can have a small classroom
which is once in the late 90s the big fad,
but if you don't have a quality teacher in
a small classroom, you're no closer; so teachers,
not size of class, teachers in the class is
where I'm at.
In my old congressional district I created
the first teaching academy high school.
[pause]
Do you guys know about the Golden Apple?
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: AUSL. I want ya to if you
don't --
>>David Lieber: We can search for it.
>>Rahm Emanuel: you can search for it.
[laughter]
Hey, don't steal my punch lines, okay?
>>David Lieber: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Rahm Emanuel: Dude, work on your own punch
lines. I was workin' on my own okay?
[laughter]
We've not gonna be doin' this much longer
if you steal my punch lines, okay?
[laughter]
Okay, okay, I've lost my train of thought
-- no.
>>David Lieber: Golden Apple.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Got it.
I want you to look it up, AUSL Program, okay?
Golden Apple here in Chicago. Anyway I created
the first high school in the old Wright Community
College. It's a master teacher, two people
in second career getting a master's in education
in the classroom, a neighborhood school.
Those teachers, when they graduate, have a
master's degree in education, signed a contract.
They will be in the Chicago Public School
System for five years. That's significant
because in the first five years every teacher
in our public school system, 50 percent of
them quit, not every, 50 percent quit. It's
too hard.
These teachers are trained for urban education.
They commit for five years minimum. Eighty
percent of 'em stay beyond the five years.
I wanna take us from seven schools to 15.
We'll graduate two high schools and six elementary
schools worth of teachers every year. After
four years Chicago will have the largest population
of teachers with a master's degree in education
and we will convert the school system, classroom
by classroom, school by school.
>>David Lieber: Can I ask, can I just interrupt
and ask? It would seem that you would need
the teacher's union cooperation for such an
accountability plan and they've --
>>Rahm Emanuel: I've --
>>David Lieber: heretofore not been willing
to commit to accountability.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Well on this thing, I worked
it out when I was running for Congress, they
support this actual program.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Eventually I wanna take it
up to 20, but the first year I'll do 15.
Now here's how I'll pay for it and after everything
I've announced, I've paid for. We spend $100
million a year at the CPS, Chicago Public
Schools, on teacher training. For $10 million,
I get these eight schools. And the reason
I'm not only for it because I get 10 out of
that for these 8 schools, I'm training teachers
who stay longer in our schools. Why do I have
to train somebody who moves to the suburbs?
I'm gettin' a better bang for our buck usin'
the same money.
You can see I get emotional about that.
Lastly, parents.
[pause]
You cannot educate kids without parents being
involved in their education. The front door
to that house or that apartment is more significant
to a child's education than the school and
then when the two of 'em are workin', they'll
be taking your job.
[laughter]
>>David Lieber: That is.
>>Rahm Emanuel: And they'll be takin' my job
and they're gonna be taking your job.
A good parent or parents involved in a kid's
education with a good school, that kid is
unstoppable. It's been proven and that's why
I said I don't get in fads. What are the three
things you gotta have? Principals that wanna
be accountable, quality teachers in a room,
and two parents who are involved. Now this
is why I love this job. I'm gonna tell you
this story.
[pause]
I told ya I used to do grocery stores and
I met probably a number of you at El stops.
>>David Lieber: Hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Okay? And I'm gonna continue
as mayor doin' somethin' retailish as a way
to always make sure I'm in touch with folks
and they're in touch with their mayor.
I was at 79th and Dan Ryan about three or
four weeks ago and I say hello to all these
high school kids regardless, not that they're
voters but one day they may be. No.
[laughter]
And this kid, Jeremy, walks, I don't know
he's Jeremy, shake hands and he goes past
me. He comes back, I don't know about 30 seconds
later whatever, and says, "Can I show you
somethin'?" And anytime a kid shows initiative
like that, you wanna be obviously responsive.
I'd be that responsive for an adult, especially
for a high school kid.
[laughter]
And he get his backpack off and is pullin'
out a piece of paper and I said, "What's this
about?" And he says, "I started an after school
program in my school." Sixteen. I said, "Really."
I go, "What does it do?" He goes, "Photography."
>>David Lieber: Um.
>>Rahm Emanuel: And he also -- in respect
to this kid, he lives up near Loyola, takes
a train all the way down 79th and gets on
a bus and goes over to Simeon; hour and twenty
transportation. So next time you're really
upset about somethin', put Jeremy in your
head for a second. He's a high schooler kid
and there's thousands of 'em out there.
I said, "Really, you run this?" He goes, "Yeah,
I develop it with a friend and I administer
it with my assistant principal." He started
his own after school program. And I said,
"Well what's this form for?" Now I'm big into
parent contracts as a way to kinda induce
responsibility. I've announced it when I announced
my education policy.
He says, "I don't let a kid into my after
school program whose parent does not sign
this." And I said, "Well what does it make
'em do?" "Pick up the report card, attend
parent-teacher conferences, and review their
homework with 'em."
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: I've announced a comprehensive
after school program for the city. We're adopting
Jeremy's contract when I'm mayor.
>>David Lieber: Ahh.
>>Rahm Emanuel: And it's not defer motion,
although there is that. And I do want people
to know that if they have an idea the mayor
or the city government will respond in the
same way that I did for the young man at the
Jewel, helped get Coonley that was on the
closed list, to now a gifted program that's
bustin' at the seams.
I introduced an elder justice bill 'cause
some lady told me how her father got beat
up at a nursing home and President Obama signed
it.
These aren't gonna solve Newtonian physics
or macroeconomics, but people give you stories
and some way you can make their lives a tad
easier or solve a problem for others.
But Jeremy came up with an idea that figured
out in my view somethin' that President Clinton
taught me very importantly. With opportunity,
after school program, comes responsibility
and accountability. And what was the other
piece of it? And at 16, Jeremy had figured
this out. And I just want you to know -- get
used to it because Jeremy's gonna be head
of the building department --
>>David Lieber: Umm-umm.
>>Rahm Emanuel: when I'm done.
[laughter]
>>David Lieber: There you go.
>>Rahm Emanuel: This kid you'd bet long on
'em. He travels an hour and 20 minutes by
himself twice a day. He developed an after
school program and knew that he had somethin'
special kids wanted or their parents wanted
for their kids, and he knew that the best
way to deduce it was to require somethin'
of the parents that wasn't happening.
>>David Lieber: Um.
>>Rahm Emanuel: I really do, I mean I mean
this is in the most fundamental way. So my
package on education is based on investing
in principals --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: raising the quality of teachers
who already a number of 'em are good, and
then making parents get off the sidelines
and involved in their kids' education.
Now to your question on the teacher's union.
They are representing their members.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
[pause]
>>Rahm Emanuel: They have in all fairness
been big advocates of parental involvement.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: No person running for office
has tried what I'm about to go try in parental
involvement. I'm gonna be a partner with them
'cause a lot of our teachers, good teachers,
work in a really tough situations. You give
'em a partner in the home, they'll be better
teachers because they finally got somebody
helpin' out with 'em --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: okay. There are places I will
disagree with the leadership. I'm a big supporter
of charters, not because I think charters
are the end all and be all. There are bad
charters and there are good charters and you
gotta be as tough on the bad charters as you
are on neighborhood schools that aren't achieving
their goal, but I'm also for neighborhood
schools that are achieving goal. I'm for all
of the above.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel. A lot of people who support
charters think they're the end. No. They're
a means towards an end. They're not the end.
And so on that topic I will disagree, but
I'll disagree from a perspective of also data.
If you take the self selective high schools
like, not limited to, Payton, Whitney on north
side, not limited to those, all the self select
is out, the seven best performing high schools
in our city are charter schools. There are
also charters that aren't doin' their job,
but I do believe in competition ?
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: I do believe in choice, and
charters are a way to give parents choice
in a public school system and I'm committed
to public education.
David Lieber: And we have a principle here
at Google called, "Data beats opinion" so
--
>>Rahm Emanuel: Well don't be so there's the
data.
>>David Lieber: Data beats itself.
[laughter]
>>Rahm Emanuel: I used to say about people
in Washington --
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: if they're firm in their opinion
it's their principles they're flexible on.
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: [laughs]
>>David Lieber: There you go.
[laughter]
You reference Newtonian physics and we actually
had some questions around that.
[laughter]
>>Rahm Emanuel: Well I'd better call my older
brother who's the smart one in the family.
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
Seriously though, one particular aspect of
education that's very important to us is the
so-called STEM curriculum: science, technology,
engineering --
>>Rahm Emanuel: Um-hum.
>>David Lieber: and mathematics because that's
what we do here and we need people coming
out of the school systems especially proficient
in those areas.
So you've outlined sort of the overall comprehensive
education vision. Is there anything specific
thoughts that you ?
>>Rahm Emanuel: Yeah.
>>David Lieber: can share regarding those
STEM type curriculum that matter to the future
of companies like Google in Chicago?
>>Rahm Emanuel: Well let's also, it's not
just matters of the future of Google. It matters
to the future of the country.
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: While you happen to get swept
into it, no disrespect, I'm more interested
in the country than I am in Google. And I
say that to you --
>>David Lieber: Sure.
>>Rahm Emanuel: I wish you all the well --
[laughter]
especially these two ladies --
>>David Lieber: And we're outta time.
[laughter]
Just go ahead.
>>Rahm Emanuel: I'll stay later. You go ahead.
[laughter]
I'm havin' fun actually and we'll handle this
without you. We just actually figured out
a way to take you out of this whole equation.
[laughter]
Here's the deal.
>>David Lieber: Yeah. [clears throat]
>>Rahm Emanuel: State of Illinois has adopted
the common standards: 39 I think or 41 other
states adopted it, but you have to have a
new curriculum to teach to the common standards.
I've already talked to a number of foundations
around the country and Chicago will be the
first city to develop the new curriculum to
teach those common standards. And those common
standards aren't for tests, but they're for
graduation and then career development and
college education. And that's the way I'm
gonna get to it.
Now let's be honest, so I don't want anybody
by the time that kid's ready to go to school,
we'll have it done in the first four years.
So Chicago will be the first city in the country
to adopt the new curriculum that goes with
the common standards.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: We also need -- part of this
whole reason I'm into my AUSL program -- is
these teachers are trained not just to get
a master's in education but specialty for
the type --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: of education you're looking
at.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum. Yep. Great.
Next most popular topic area was around taxes.
There've been a lot of -- I guess kerfuffle
is the word -- over the past week of this
tax plan and that tax plan and disinformation
and counter information, can you just clear
the air --
>>Rahm Emanuel: We got you right where we
want you.
>>David Lieber: In ahh. In plain English,
what's your tax plan?
>>Rahm Emanuel: Oh, with that burden, plain
English? Okay here it is.
>>David Lieber: [clears throat]
>>Rahm Emanuel: I believe that we deserve
a 20 percent tax cut in the sales tax. City
of Chicago has one of the highest sales tax
in the country.
[pause]
Now I've proposed three separate tax cuts.
The other two -- the elimination of the head
tax --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: which is you wanna add employees
--
>>David Lieber: Yep.
>>Rahm Emanuel: would help you. I also proposed
a sales -- tax reform in the utility and natural
gas tax so right now it's structured as the
price goes up, you pay more. I want it to
be on a per unit basis so your usage is what
drives it which makes you more energy conservation
and it saves the consumer money.
Now in the sales tax I propose a 20 percent
reduction. We tax only a few items, so a single
mother who's trying to buy school supplies
is bearing that burden. Now I'm only sayin'
it right here to you so just get ready.
[pause]
You charter a private jet -- you're not paying
anything now. I don't want that single mother
to bear that burden alone. A lot of your clients
rent limos comin' in from the airport -- they
don't pay anything right now. I'm gonna extend
it there. I'm telling you this up front. I
do not think a single mother should be bearing
this burden alone; she's tryin' to raise kids;
she's tryin' to get 'em to school; she deserves
a tax cut; she's workin'.
Now my whole life was about tax fairness.
That's why I got on the Ways and Means as
a member of the House in Congress. And workin'
for President Clinton, President Obama, I
doubled the earned income tax credit. And
not only doubled it and fought Republican's
attempts to fight it, in my office we used
it with the tax assistance program to fill
out tax forms for working poor 'cause I fundamentally
in the marrow of my bones believe if you're
working, your kid does not deserve to grow
up in poverty.
So I not only passed that legislation and
protected it, I helped people in my district
get $2 million worth of tax cuts. They would
get --
>>David Lieber: Hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: $3200, $2800, $1800 back.
And for a single mother or a family, that's
Christmas and the entire year's worth of savings.
[pause]
And not only that, you couple it with a children's
health care bill that made sure that, usually
those single mothers are young working poor
families that didn't have health care at the
place of employment, made sure that their
kids got health care. I made sure that the
minimum wage, I said in Congress -- I led
the effort -- there'll be no pay raise in
Congress until we raise the minimum wage.
Now I gotta tell you somethin'. My grandfather
was a union man. He used to sing a song to
us, "Which Side Are You On?". I'm gonna stand
with that single mother. I got no problem
with that.
>>David Lieber: Um.
>>Rahm Emanuel: And if you rent a corporate
jet and you're comin' to Chicago, we're gonna
make that single mother make sure she can
get that from paycheck to paycheck just a
little more. You rent a limo, you're gonna
carry some of that burden so she gets a tax
cut. You wanna join Saddle and Cycle private,
exclusive club -- I don't have a problem with
any of these activities, but the reason we
have one of the highest sales taxes in the
country is working people are bearin' the
burden alone. And folks, that ain't right.
And also it won't solve Newtonian physics
but people in this city are gettin' nickeled
and dimed by taxes all the time. And one of
the reasons is because we got this thing turned
upside down. We're puttin' too few people
paying on too few items when a lot of other
people are gettin' a break.
And if workin' for President Obama, President
Clinton, and working for the people of 5th
District taught me that on taxes we have to
be fair, we have to be equitable. And it is
wrong that a single mother is now paying a
bigger share of their taxes than people renting
corporate jets, limousines, or joining private
clubs. And I'm tellin' this to you for some
of your people that are comin' in here that
will change for them. But that is a bare sensible
fairness and it's good economics because if
we can lower the rate, Chicago will be a better
city. Fortune just rated one of the reasons
Chicago was difficult to live in for the sales
tax.
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Well let's get it cut.
>>David Lieber: So when you frame that issue
as the single mom versus the private corporate
jet, it's very compelling.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Um-hum.
>>David Lieber: The counter argument has been
though that the economic health of the city
depends on small businesses and the individual
massage, masseuse tryin' to work, earn a living,
start a small business, the gym, those people
will actually be bearing the burden, not the
corporate jets.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Well okay first of all --
>>David Lieber: So how do you respond to that?
>>Rahm Emanuel: Two things: civic federations
endorse what I said.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: The Chicago Sun Times has
endorsed my proposal, the Chicago Retail Merchants
--
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: representing the small businesses
endorsed my proposal. All have said that because
small business is the engine --
>>David Lieber: Yep.
>>Rahm Emanuel: and making sure. The other
thing is I said we'll have to work out the
details with Springfield. That's where this
is decided and I will accept nothing that
violates the principle of a tax cut for working
families.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: That's number one.
Number two, in a similar format, in a debate
at WTTW with a bunch of high school students,
the reason this became an issue is a high
school student asked me and one of my opponents
that the sales taxes were too high. The specific
question by a 16 year old and I said I supported
gettin' a cut in the sales tax. One of my
opponents said he agreed with me. Two weeks
before an election, all of a sudden, he disagrees.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: I don't think that's really
fair to the 16 year old who you told eye to
eye you agreed on somethin'.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Now the retail merchants who
represent the small businesses in Chicago
that drive the economy support this idea.
>>David Lieber: Yep. Okay.
We had some other fiscal questions. One was
around privatization.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Um.
>>David Lieber: So the question says, "We
sold off the Skyway Bridge then the parking
meters. Now there's talk of privatizing the
Taste of Chicago and other festivals. These
kinds of fiscal initiatives are generally
or universally unliked by Chicagoans." What
do you think here?
>>Rahm Emanuel: Well two things: one I'm against
privatization --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: it's run its -- folks aren't
for it. I don't think the capital markets
are for it --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: you can't do it. I will say
usually we're a city known that divides over
education and crime. I give the mayor credit
for bringing the city together. People all
across --
>>David Lieber: [chuckles]
>>Rahm Emanuel: the city hate the parking
deal.
[laughter]
>>David Lieber: I let ya have that punch line.
>>Rahm Emanuel: That's right.
[laughter]
I didn't know Christmas was comin' early.
>>David Lieber: [laughs]
>>Rahm Emanuel: So that has made --
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: folks are against it and I'm
against it. Here's the other thing though,
we have to figure out how to monetize certain
assets. That doesn't mean selling 'em or gettin'
rid of 'em. I'm against that. I said that
clearly, unambiguously. But a way to get some
value out of them so we can invest in what
I think is a key priority.
One of the things I wanna get to -- you haven't
asked, I'm just gonna go there. I am big into
our investment in our mass transit system,
okay. No other city outside of New York has
more people use their mass transit to get
to and from work. In a Fortune study, not
Fortune, a study done by, I forgot who, that's
bad. But people in Chicago have rated both
our night life, our restaurants, our culture,
and our mass transit system with the quality
of life of what they love about the city.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: I -- when I first got to Congress
-- got the funding to expand the Brown Line.
It used to be six cars; it's now eight cars,
Brown Line, modern stations. It makes getting
to and from work, the whole experience, much
better, quicker. We have to invest in our
mass transit system. There are other infrastructure
needs. I'm telling you before the election
what numero uno is for me. You need to know
that. And of the people that take the mass
transit, the Red Line is used by 40 percent
of 'em and it's been the least invested in.
Now there's differences. On the north side
and the south side, but we gotta modernize
it. So the same type of stations, the same
type of capacity. On the south side, it's
gotta be taken from 95th to 130th. You can't
ask people to participate in an economy if
they can't get there.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: It artificially stops at 95th.
People live all the way to 130th. How do you
get to work?
I know I see a number of you on bicycles.
That's how I know you get to work.
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emaneual: Okay?
[laughter]
Which is my second point. I've announced a
plan to -- we do eight miles a year -- I'm
gonna do 25 miles a year of new bike lanes
in the city. I want it to become a major,
for folks who wanna do it, means of getting
to and from work, not just dodgin' in and
out of traffic. And we're gonna make dedicated
lanes that are safe. I'm gonna add 25 miles
so by the end of my term, if I'm elected,
100 miles of new bike lanes in the city.
I'm also gonna look to change the ordinance
so buildings like this will give people the
space and the capacity to both park their
bikes securely and be able to change and get
to work if they bike to work. And I will say
this not just for the Googles but actually
for the new Googles of the world, that's gonna
be a big piece of economic development because
it's gonna attract a work force that's sees
a city that allows them to get to and from
work and the quality of life that they want.
>>David Lieber: Um.
>>Rahm Emanuel: The bulk will use mass transit.
That's what I did when I was both a Congressman
and worked in the private sector.
>>David Lieber: Um.
>>Rahm Emanuel: There's no doubt that my kids
when they grow up will probably bike. Their
mother will yell at them to wear a helmet,
okay. But I want that, that's two pieces,
I want that investment strategy I think it's
key to who we're gonna be as a city and it's
one of our advantages compared to other cities
when companies are lookin' at that you can
get to and from work with relative convenience
is a big selling point besides your education
and your caliber as employees.
>>David Lieber: And as you may know these
Googlers in this room are responsible for
getting --
>>Rahm Emanuel: I've never heard that. Are
you guys actually called Googlers?
>>David Lieber: Googlers, yeah.
[laughter]
>>Rahm Emanuel: God, I'm empathetic to you.
>>David Lieber: But these folks were responsible
for getting the city's existing bike lane
routes up and findable on Google Maps so it's
not just --
>>Rahm Emanuel: Oh.
>>David Lieber: maps of mass transit or maps
of roads or cars. It's for bike lanes --
>>Rahm Emanuel: I just pointed to my policy
guy. Well that's good.
>>David Lieber: And Chicago, by the way, was
the very first major city to have its bike
maps on Google Maps. So we look forward to
partnering with you --
>>Rahm Emanuel: Well, get ready 'cause were
adding 25 a year, man.
[laughter]
>>David Lieber: There you go.
So you mentioned Google on the --
>>Rahm Emanuel: Googlers?
>>David Lieber: Googlers.
[laughter]
>>Rahm Emanuel: I'm gonna have to try and
throw a line tonight at a debate for you,
Matt.
>>David Lieber: Alright.
[laughter]
>>Rahm Emanuel: Googlers? That's really --
There's a line there but it's being videoed.
And I'm not touchin' it.
[laughter]
>>David Lieber: Alright.
Then we'll move on.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Okay.
>>David Lieber: So you mentioned for the Googlers
--
>>Rahm Emanuel: It's the first time we've
ever had a seven second delay on the Google
video.
[laughter]
>>David Lieber: There you go.
You mentioned for the Googles of the world
and the future Googles -- one of your recent
policy talks, you cited Groupon, BrightTag,
Threadless Google -- we thank you for that
as examples sort of leaders in Chicago's tech
community coming from different perspectives
and whatnot. What's your plan to attract companies
like these? You've talked about a biomedical
campus at Michael Reese. How do you see the
tech community playing in your plans?
>>Rahm Emanuel: Well let's be clear on a couple
things.
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: One is I do actually think
what I talked about transportation's --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: a key piece.
>>David Lieber: Yep.
>>Rahm Emanuel: I announced in my speech that
we're gonna build a campus like situation
for like Google use out in California, I wanna
do that here. I wanna work with some of the
high tech startup companies about that type
of space, but as you mentioned as we were
walkin' through here. One of the reasons you
obviously provide food as a company --
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: but if you guys can solve
a problem here, it's more efficient that way.
I want that sense of innovation, creativity
where then two young people are talkin' and
it may become a company --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: of the future. We don't know
but that campus like environment environmentally
is clearly key not just culturally but economically.
But young startups that are doing Web type
companies --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: are different than people
that are going to be doing pharmaceutical
and new health care companies. The University
of Chicago is investing in a new bioengineering
center which is unbelievably important for
the city and for the country. I wanna create
a campus that allows new health care companies
to feed off that, but that's a different culture
-- let's be clear -- than the people that
would be ?
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: in the startup companies.
It's a total different kind of mindset, lifestyle,
instincts. Not a lot of 'em will be riding
bikes to work, but that we have to kinda do
that. We are a home to 13 separate wind companies,
fitting for the windy city.
>>David Lieber: Hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: But --
>>David Lieber: But that's probably not widely
known.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Thirteen, actually more than
any other city in the country, Chicago.
>>David Lieber: Hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Wind, wind, I'm sorry. I know
it's hard for the Googlers to hear, okay?
[laughter]
I'm going to go for the whole week off that
one.
[laughter]
So those are some of the things. The other
thing, and I mention this to you as though
--
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: maybe that was a slow pitch
off the center for me, is we are going to
have, if I'm mayor, I'm gonna pick kind of
a long weekend, a Thursday through Sunday,
music, food, etcetera, but a weekend where
we recruit the juniors and seniors from around
the 10 state area and also Illinois in the
math and science and engineering departments
to come see Chicago.
I'm gonna get all the companies, the Googles
and the Googlers to the pharmaceutical companies,
to other tech companies, to the startup companies,
to the established, to the financial companies,
but I want these people not just from Purdue
and the University of Illinois but I'm including
northern Illinois, I'm including the schools
here, I'm including our community colleges,
but I'm gonna go to Lansing, I'm goin' to
Madison, I'm gonna go to Des Moines, I'm gonna
go down to St. Louis, and I'm gonna recruit
those juniors and seniors and I said I'm gonna
sell Chicago. And you are going to be a partner
in selling it. They'll probably be staying
at an apartment near you.
>>David Lieber: Hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: In your apartment. Not you
because --
>>David Lieber: [laughs]
>>Rahm Emanuel: you, I wouldn't let 'em near
it.
[laughter]
Okay? But I'm serious about that. But I really
want -- here's the deal when I first helped
Mayor Daley get elected, we had to just run
the city. You still gotta do that which gets
to the first question that we talked about
--
>>David Lieber: Yep.
>>Rahm Emanuel: delivering services to the
taxpayers.
But today you're an ambassador to the world
at large about your city. That's a new part
of the job. It's developed over the last 10
years. San Antonio is a competitor, so is
Shanghai.
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Louisville is a competitor,
so is London. I wanna sell Chicago and our
quality of life, our companies, our structures.
So as you told me, you're trying hire 100,
200 people.
>>David Lieber: Yep.
>>Rahm Emanuel: I wanna make sure that there's
five applicants for those openings of quality.
I did mention Groupon. They hire 180 a week
?
[pause]
400 a month, five applicants per opening.
And they've told me, Eric's told me. They
got people everyone of those five are capable
of hiring, taking that position, and they
have tough choices. I'm hopin' that's true
for you. I did talk to another company, Deloitte
Touche, they're gonna hire 500. They are actually
finding it difficult to find the full talent;
that's a high class problem we should solve.
And I also gotta be clear to you
[pause]
I want people throughout the city to participate
in that. That just can't be an opportunity
for part of the city.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: We gotta be frank and honest
with ourselves in this room. Right now Google,
Groupon, it's great, it's promising, I'm happy,
I want you to grow, I want you to grow in
Chicago, I want Chicago to be a bigger presence
for Google than it is today.
But I want everybody who's growing in all
parts of this city to have an opportunity
to see Google in their future and we gotta
be frank and honest with ourselves. That's
just not true. And that's not the city we
want either. So I want you to make Google
on Google and all you Googlers feel at home
in Chicago, I want you to grow, I want you
to prosper, but I want everybody, I want Jeremy
who's going to Simeon on the west side, I
want him to think Google's in his future.
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: But we'd be and -- this one
I don't want you to interrupt for a second
and I love you.
[laughter]
Not that much to let you interrupt.
Part of being mayor and part of being a chief
executive and given the level of our difficulties
as a city and our challenges is leveling with
people. And part of running for mayor is you
get big experiences that are wider than what
you'd normally do.
[pause]
Google, I don't mean to pick on Jeremy, but
you've gotta be honest you know that in large
parts of our city, Google's just not part
of people's world views of what they think
they can be part of. And I want that. We're
known as a city that builds big things ?
[pause]
big airports, big mass transits, Millennium
Park; those are good things to be known for.
The biggest thing we can build is the vision
of our children and I want Google to be part
of that vision.
[pause]
You got somethin' you wanna add.
[laughter]
>>David Lieber: We'd be pleased and proud
to be part of it.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Good. That's one of the kind
of corporation I want to be part of this city
and all the rest of the Googlers. I just had
to work that in one more time.
[laughter]
>>David Lieber: We'll take some live questions,
but line up at the mics guys go ahead.
>>Rahm Emanuel: How do you guys call live
questions? Is there a special word for that
too?
[laughter]
>>David Lieber: As opposed to dead questions,
okay?
But let's do a quick speed round.
>>Rahm Emanuel: This is unfair to my former
-- never mind, I won't do that.
[laughter]
>>David Lieber: Let's do a quick speed round
while the Googlers are lining up.
Fast lightning round. Another Olympia bid,
yes or no?
>>Rahm Emanuel: I'm fine with it but I'm not
gonna become a one trick pony on economic
development. That is I'm for it, but I'm not
gonna pin the entire city's future economically
on a one trick pony 'cause I don't believe
in lettin' people, that's just A the simple
answer yes, but it's not the ticket to our
economic future alone.
>>David Lieber: Cubs or Sox?
>>Rahm Emanuel: Cubs.
[cheering]
But I will go, no --
[laughter]
Cubs, but I'm gonna go obviously go down to
Comiskey Park and watch the game.
>>David Lieber: Last YouTube video you watched?
>>Rahm Emanuel: Alright.
[laughter]
Okay I'm gonna tell this story.
We get to see this video before it goes out
right, no.
This is a true story. Now you gotta understand,
I'm runnin' for office, okay --
>>David Lieber: [laughs]
>>Rahm Emanuel: I got a lot on my plate, guys.
I don't remember. It's earlier than summer.
Have you ever seen the video, you'll understand
this why I'm takin' time buildin' up the confidence
--
>>David Lieber: [laughs]
>>Rahm Emanuel: to tell this story.
[laughter]
Have you ever seen the video of our soldiers
in Afghanistan done to Lady Gaga?
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Okay the telephone.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Okay. That, I'm gonna protect
the innocence of one of my children. Early,
early before this thing went really went viral,
one of my kids said, "Dad have you seen this?"
This is the parts of parenting you're gonna
just love.
[laughter]
I'm serious about this. I said, "No." So that's
a sign for Googleing.
[laughter]
So we look it up, we do find it, and I watch
this video. If you haven't seen it you can
look it up Afghanistan, soldiers, Lady Gaga,
the telephone. So I watch this video, I'm
laughin' hysterical, also admirable as a former
dancer their quality.
[laughter]
They got their lines and sense of music unbelievably
well. So I forgot. Well anyway it was like
within the first week it came out. So Monday,
it's in the week so the next day the President
often has, once a week he has a meeting with
Secretary Gates of Defense and Head of Joint
Chiefs Mike Mullen. So as we're waiting to
go into the Oval, I said to Secretary Gates,
I said, "Hey have you seen this video --
[laughter]
on Afghanistan I call Lady Gaga you know the
telephone?" Now you can imagine Gates and
Mullen, I mean if it ain't in my world view,
and I'm just a notch cooler, not much okay
--
[laughter]
it ain't in their world view.
So I said, "Don't worry about repealing Don't
ask, don't tell. The soldiers in Kandahar
already did it for ya."
>>David Lieber: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Rahm Emanuel: [laughs] So they went and
watched it and Gates called, and Mullen and
Gates individually called, I'm sorry Secretary
Gates and Head of Joint Chiefs of Staff, Mike
Mullen called back and says, "Oh my God."
[laughter]
And they were all, it became a good laugh
for us.
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: So that was the last time
I can say -- that's a long story. A lot more
serious work got done in the White House --
>>David Lieber: [laughs]
[laughter]
>>Rahm Emanuel: But I will tell you that was
the last time I really could say I saw a good
video and I said Secretary, "I'm just tellin'
ya --
>>David Lieber: Yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: the troops are ahead of you,
man.
[laughter]
Get with it. As I always note you wanted to
lead your troops. Get in front man that is
some good dancers who understand music.
[laughter]
>>David Lieber: There you go.
>>Rahm Emanuel: And it's, have some people
seen this video?
>>David Lieber: Yeah, sure.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Okay, it's a great video.
>>David Lieber: Good. Alright.
With that, go ahead.
>>Brian Benedict: Hi.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Your question's gonna look
so small now compared to that great story
--
>>Brian Benedict I don't know, I don't know.
I'm just, that actually kinda segues into
my question. My name is Brian Benedict and
I head up the Gay-glers which is another name
for you. It's LGBT Googlers here within the
office.
>>Rahm Emanuel: I got that part.
>>Brian Benedict: There we go.
[laughter]
>>Rahm Emanuel: Okay, okay.
>>Brian Benedict: You know Google has been
--
>>Rahm Emanuel: I'll refer to you as Mr. Gay-gler
>>Brian Benedict: That works.
>>Rahm Emanuel: okay? And everyone of you
behind are Mr. and Mrs. Googler, okay.
>>Brian Benedict: So my question is, well
Google has been great. They pay for the taxes
for same sex marriages --
>>Rahm Emanuel: Um-hum.
>>Brian Benedict: in regards to health benefits
and whatnot and we've recently approved civil
unions. So I kinda wanna get your perspective
on the LGBT community and same sex marriages
basically.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Thumbs up, for it, big time
for it.
>>Brian Benedict: Right. Well, that was easy.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Okay, no, but no, here's the
deal. Go right back to that microphone one
second.
[laughter]
No I'm, here's the deal.
[pause]
First when I was a congressman I had secured
the funding for the Halsted Street Center.
At that point it was the largest federal support
ever given to a gay or lesbian organization
in the country. And it's an incredibly great
community center for the gay and lesbian community
in our city throughout the city, not just
people in Boystown or Andersonville; that's
key to remember because they are our teachers,
they are our fellow colleagues and they live
throughout the city, not just in part of the
city.
Two, I cannot be happier that I was Chief
of Staff when we finally passed and President
Obama signed into law the hate crimes law
and ran the process to get that done in the
name of Matthew Shepard.
And then three, this is about, part of life
is also being able to learn. Okay I was once
in my life in a hospital for seven weeks,
nearly died. Family came to visit, etcetera.
David Buell, who's a dear friend of mine and
Amy and our kids -- travel together, vacation
together and Tom his partner. They happened
to be in D.C., David who has been the treasurer
of my campaign for Congress. He's the treasurer
now for me running for Mayor, David and Tom.
David told me about a story and I've been
around health care 'cause my dad's a pediatrician,
my mother's a nurse, my brother's an oncologist,
told me about a woman in Florida who'd been
written up in the gay papers down there who
was kicked out of the room of a hospital because
her partner was dying but was not a family
member.
>>David Lieber: Hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Now okay I just got, again
I wanna level, that's not in my world view.
It wasn't in my world experience in the same
way that dealing with the issue of food deserts
and we haven't discussed, wasn't in my world
view.
And I looked into it and I went to the President
and I said, "This is wrong." And with his
direction worked through both the White House
Council, Health and Human Services, the Justice
Department under Eric Holder, and the President.
We developed it for six months -- an executive
order. If any hospitals receiving any federal
money they can no longer ban loved ones who
are partners from being by the bedside of
their loved ones.
And while part of civil union and marriage
is all about-- let's get real here -- it's
all about not -- it's about love, but it's
also about what we all in this room who are
straight take for granted and making sure
that that's available for gay couples: visiting
a hospital, sharing health care benefits,
getting a retirement and sharing it.
Things that if you are gay are accepted, or
rather that if you are straight that are accepted
that you have to struggle to get to a level
playing field if you're gay or lesbian and
that is not true today. Now it is, now that
we have civil union, it is because we had
a President that had the courage on hate crimes,
had signed an executive order and repealed
Don't Ask Don't Tell and a Governor and a
state legislature who passed civil unions
here. It levels the playing field of equity,
fairness, and full citizenship.
>>Brian Benedict: Thank you.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Thank you for askin'.
>>David Lieber: Okay.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Ladies and gentlemen, Ms.
Google.
>>female #1: [laughs]
>>Rahm Emanuel: Her. I am going to take this
all the way through the weekend I decided.
[laughter]
Go ahead.
>>female #1: Hello. So I don't have a problem
saying that the Hyde Park question is my question.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Right.
>>female #1: I live in Hyde Park. We live
about two blocks from the Ray Elementary School.
So when my baby was in my belly like hers
is I wasn't thinkin' about this. But now my
daughter is four and kindergarten is the next
step and we're lookin' around. So I understand
the suggestion of your plan to have it so
that the schools, the teachers in the schools
are well and they come home and the parents
interact with the students well that's great.
However, what if it seems like those schools
that are doing really great are miraculously
somehow outside of your district?
>>Rahm Emaneul: Hum.
>>female #1: You can -- you either have to
move into the district and if it's a small,
I mean you know about Hyde Park. You can barely
move your elbow before you're touching somebody
next to you. So if you've got a really tight
residency in that district, then you need
to go to the school in your district, but
what if that school is not up to par with
the standards you like for your own child?
>>Rahm Emanuel: Well that's -- A that's why
I wanna have these five year performance contracts
so I can start improving. B what I haven't
mentioned -- two other things --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: I am a firm believer, having
worked with President Obama and Arne Duncan,
I'm a firm believer in Race to the Top as
a model to spur innovation. We're gonna create
a Race to the Top just for Chicago so I can
spur local school innovation that improves
teacher quality, improves test scores, improves
parental participation. I'm gonna invest in
the things that I know produce success.
Third I wanna be the first city to adopt the
parent trigger. Okay, California did it. Parent
trigger -- your school's rated, I pick three
years but we could do two years, three years
in a row it's failing -- I'm gonna give the
parents six months; you get 51 percent of
the parents that sign a petition; I'm shuttin'
the schools down and I'm workin' with the
parents on what they want and replace.
>>female #1: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emaneul: That's how I'm gonna do this.
Okay I'm not now, up front, year one I ain't
turnin' the whole thing around. It's a big
institution of a lot of years. I gotta build,
which I why I wanna invest in the fundamentals
to move this thing to a place that every neighborhood
school and schools that you wanna go have
the capacity. The only way I know how to do
that is spend the money smart, invest in the
things that have proven over history, and
after study after study to work: parents,
teachers, and principals.
>>female #1: Thank you.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Thank you. And thanks for
askin'. And you, trust me, both of you this
is gonna be your concern in no time.
>>female #1: [ ].
>>Rahm Emanuel: Yeah.
>>David Lieber: Let's take the last couple
of --
>>Rahm Emanuel: Coming to a theater near you.
Go ahead.
>>Stasha Hello, my name is Stasha and as a
dancer myself I think you may have won me
over with your comment about Joffrey.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Um.
>>female #2: Um.
>>Rahm Emanuel: What kind of dance did you
do?
>>female #2: I still do, I, well I did, I
was a dance major in college and I currently
dance the Chicago Bulls so kinda just the
background of like ballet and a lot and --
>>Rahm Emanuel: Jazz?
>>female #2: All types of dance, yeah.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Okay.
Welcome to our conversation on dance, guys.
[laughter]
>>Stasha: Well my question is about the Sweet
Home Chicago campaign proposal to possibly
set aside 20 percent of all TIF funds to affordable
housing and I just wanted to know your take
on that and, yeah, what your thoughts were
on that.
>>Rahm Emanuel: One is -- look we have to
deal with affordable housing. Second, we have
to reform TIF's so before I put more mandates
on TIF's, I gotta a lot of reforms we gotta
make. TIF's are the fastest growing part of
the city's budget and they're not in the city's
budget. Get them in the budget.
Two, bring full transparency to them.
Three, even after 20 plus years or 30 years
of TIF's being around we still don't have
a standard that is this TIF reaching its economic
development goals, its job goals? Develop
that standard so we can measure the progress
of the TIF.
Third, in some communities, economic development
is gonna be affordable housing. In other communities
it's gonna be the retail type of commercial
work. Mandating something before I've made
all the necessary reforms to a TIF process
would be a mistake in my view. In addition
to that, TIF's are for blighted economic communities
that are struggling. We have to shut down
the number of the TIF's that are in high rent
areas right now.
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: There's $950 million of unused
TIF funds; some of them have lived past their
value. And if I shut them down because they're
no longer there and they have surplus, guess
what -- who wins? The schools win because
the money will go from there back into the
property taxes to pay for schools.
So I'm okay with some of them being used for
affordable housing, but not until I get the
whole TIF process and TIF system reformed.
And also if I mandate a new mandate those,
what happens to the ones that are doing really
well and making progress in economic development
-- merely on the commercial side?
>>female #2: Um.
>>Rahm Emanuel: So that's why, let's reform
the TIF's, let's get 'em on the budget, let's
bring a level of transparency, let's set up
a standard for economic progress to measure
before we offer a new mandate. And some are
already doing that and that doesn't mean that
TIF's are the only way to achieve our goals
on affordable housing. Okay?
>>female #2: Alright. Thank you.
>>Rahm Emanuel: And we are gonna talk dance
later.
>>David Lieber: [chuckles]
>>female #2: Alright.
[laughter]
>>Rahm Emanuel: You wanna do --
>>David Lieber: Shall we take the final question
here?
>>Rahm Emanuel: Final, I'm okay on time?
>>David Lieber: Final question.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Final question. Last round.
>>Tiffany: Hi. Okay, no pressure. So my names
Tiffany and I was born and raised in Chicago
up on the West Side in the Austin area, north
Lawndale --
>>Rahm Emanuel: Um-hum.
>>Tiffany: and I currently live in Humboldt
Park and I really wanted to ask you what your
plan is for what can only be called epidemic
of violence in our city particularly in the
poor neighborhoods, and what your plan is
in your first 100 days as mayor and long term
as mayor to really curb --
>>Rahm Emanuel: Hum.
>>Tiffany: an epidemic of violence --
>>Rahm Emanuel: Oh, okay.
>>Tiffany: because I was overseas and --
>>Rahm Emanuel: I thought you said what was
my plan for the 100 days across the board
of issues.
>>Tiffany: [laughs] No, no.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Okay. Alright.
Well that is a good question. First of all
I wanna just before I get to crime can I say
somethin' about North Lawndale? There is,
where I gave my education speech was at the
Bethune School in North Lawndale. It is now
one of the teaching academies that I told
you about. The principal there, Ms. Hightower,
is co-chair of my campaign. In one year they've
raised their reading scores 20 percent. Same
kids from the neighborhood, same building,
different principal, different teachers, scores
are up. All graduates of this teaching academy
model.
Now what I'm very impressed also one of the
things I wanna get to I can't do it overnight
again, there's Bethune, there's Johnson, and
there's a Collins High School not too far
and they're all part this. I wanna create
those campuses where a family knows from kindergarten
to high school, they got an excellent program.
>>David Lieber: Um.
>>Rahm Emanuel: I do not wanna see these parents
on ninth grade goin' into a cliff. I'm gonna
get you cryin' but I want you to know in your
old neighborhood, North Lawndale, there's
a beacon of hope and it's got a heartbeat
and it's beating bright.
Two: crime. For President Clinton, I was his
point person on crime in the White House.
We passed the assault weapon ban, the Brady
Bill which is a five day waiting period for
hand guns, the 100,000 community police officers
program, the Violence Against Women Act, Megan's
Law --
>>David Lieber: Um-hum.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Sexual predator moves into
a neighborhood out of prison, the community's
notified. And when I was a congressman, Elder
Justice Act which I told you came from a lady
at a grocery store tellin' me about it which
is the first time in five years, first time
that the federal law recognized crimes again
seniors, be they financial or physical.
I've outlined a very specific plan based on
the '94 crime bill. A thousand additional
police on the street and getting kids and
guns off the street. It has to be comprehensive.
The police doing community policing, backing
up the beat officers are the backbone of the
police department.
The after school program, I already told you
about Jeremy. Two-thirds of all juvenile crime
the hours of three to six. School is out,
mom or mom and dad aren't home. Get these
kids into the adult supervised activities
so they're not victims of crime.
And then third, prosecution of our gun laws.
Would I like more gun laws? I'm gonna fight
for it. Do I think if we're not gettin' new
gun laws after what happened in Tucson, Arizona
-- I'm not pinnin' my hopes on either Springfield
or Washington wakin' up.
Now our State's Attorneys you've seen in the
news, Scott Cutt's coming. They prosecute
our gun crimes. That's why I've called for
the U.S. Attorney to start supporting what
we're doing on prosecuting gun crimes. I don't
see them laying off any lawyers.
So more cops on the beat, kids, guns, and
drugs off the street. That's the strategy;
you add a thousand additional officers, do
the reforms, and everything I just told you
on my website, I know you know how to Google
and go there and you can find exactly how
I pay for it and how I accomplish it.
And I'm also gonna, and where we started,
I wanna change the philosophy and that philosophy
in the police department is that the bureaucracy
is not the backbone, the beat officer is the
backbone. Everything we do is to back up that
beat officer.
I can't thank you enough and I look around
here and I see the promise of Chicago. I will
come back as mayor if I'm elected and do this
and I expect another 100 people hired by Google,
if not 200.
[applause]
Thank you.
>>David Lieber: Thank you. We have a bike
shirt for you.
>>Rahm Emanuel: [laughs]
[applause]
>>David Lieber: This is our Google Chicago
logo. Here you are.
>>Rahm Emanuel: Thank you so much. Thank you
guys. Thank you very much.
[applause]